hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on one core concept from
an important philosophical text i hope
you find it useful as well
in his essay what libertarianism is john
hospers clarifies for us the
relationship for libertarians between
the individual
and government and then business is
something sort of in between
and he's going to clarify how it is that
business and government would also
relate to each other there's also some
implications if we read between the
lines
for the relationships between a business
if it gets large enough if it gets
powerful enough if it acts enough like a
government
and an individual
but he doesn't clarify that as such so
we'll read that in there
hospers begins
by telling us the standard libertarian
position that the best government is one
that is small
and that stays within if we want to use
a contemporary term stays within its
lane what is the purpose of a government
he says that the proper role of a
government is to protect the
rights of the citizens protect citizens
against aggression
by other individuals notice that he says
citizens so he's not saying the role of
the government is to protect everybody
in the in the world no it's just to
protect those who belong within its its
borders right
or you know its members outside of its
borders and in some other place against
violations of their rights
and the rights for the libertarians that
matter are life liberty and property so
he says the function of government
is to take a responsibility off of our
shoulders what's the responsibility well
it would be rather inefficient for us to
try to protect all of our rights on our
own as he says if each of us had to
defend himself against possible
aggressors we'd have to spend a lot of
our time in target practice karate
exercises other means of self-discipline
and
defenses and we might even be helpless
against groups of individuals
so that would rule out you know the
improvements in science medicine arts
likely uh you know and civilized life
right so it's very efficient to have a
government to do that protection and he
says the function of government is to
take this responsibility on the
government undertakes to defend us
against aggressors and to punish them if
they attack that's the basic level that
he wants to see
so you know you could have minimal taxes
in order to pay for those protective
services but the government from the
libertarian position shouldn't be
involved in all sorts of other things
like say health care
or you know inspecting factories or
anything like that ideally from you know
depending on how far you go along the
libertarian spectrum maybe the
government shouldn't even really spend
that much time on roads or you know like
taking care of snow plowing or things
like that um
the other thing that he tells us another
main point it's summed up in this
statement that he has government is the
most dangerous institution known to man
and why does he say that well again from
the libertarian perspective
government has a bad track record of
transgressing people's rights and he
gives us sort of a laundry list of the
things that government
now he's kind of you know talking about
government per se
not any individual government which
could say well i do we don't do that but
he's saying government in the past has
killed people enslaved them sent them to
force labor and concentration camps
regularly robbed and pillaged them of
the fruits of their expended labor
and and government is also dangerous in
part because it's so powerful
as he points out
government can surround and encompass a
person totally dominating every aspect
of one's life so that one has no
recourse from it but to leave the
country and in some countries
totalitarian countries even that's not
permitted so government is is got a bad
track record um and government is too
strong to you know if if it's not
kept in check it's going to be abusive
so he talks then another main point
about what kind of laws a government
should be in the business of enacting
and this is again very typical
libertarian doctrine one type of law
protects individuals against themselves
and he gives as prime examples of that
um laws against various types of
fornication that is sexual morality
right and
alcohol drugs we might think about other
ordinances that have been passed against
say dancing or
being tattooed or anything like that
anything where somebody can say that's
not good for you so we're not gonna let
you do it right and libertarians are
totally against that sort of law why
because it interferes with the right
perhaps not just to
liberty which is paramount here but
could interfere with with somebody's
property as well so that's a prime
consideration
what else
the second kind of law protects
individuals against aggression by others
and he says that libertarians
are entirely for this
aggression by individuals against other
individuals should be ruined out the the
laws who function as to protect human
beings against encroachment by this
that's perfectly legitimate the third
kind of law
is where we see some sort of transfer of
wealth or resources or perhaps even time
we're requiring people to help each
other
and hasper says libertarians are against
that you might say well why would they
be against that what's wrong
with helping somebody else there's
nothing wrong with helping somebody else
as a matter of fact libertarians may
choose voluntarily to help other people
but they want to be able to choose
without coercion without the government
telling them that they have to
contribute for that so he says no one
should be forced by law to help others
not even to tell them the time of day if
requested
and certainly not to give them a portion
of their weekly paycheck
he goes on and he talks about
rights and he says many people
you know claim virtually everything that
one needs or desires as one's right so
you may say you have a right to a job
the right to free medical care the right
to free food and clothing to a decent
home and so on and then the question is
well whose expense does this come at
if it's coming at anybody's expense who
didn't voluntarily contribute that like
say in a charity
then from the libertarian perspective
it's illegitimate but this is what
government spends a lot of its time
and resources doing
so he says if you have a right to a job
who has to supply it does an employer
supply it even if he doesn't want to
hire you what if you're unemployable or
incurably lazy if you say the government
must supply it does that mean that a job
must be created which no employer needs
done and you must be kept in it
regardless of how much or little you
work
if an employer is forced to supply it as
it is
at his expense even if he doesn't need
you isn't he being enslaved isn't
aggression being carried out against him
and he does a similar examination of
medical care
of other things as well
and this leads him to
a fourth point having to do with the
relationship between
libertarianism individuals and
government but it's mediated through
businesses
he wants to see
less government control ideally no
government control over most parts of
the economy a totally free market and
the idea behind that is he says that
with the restrictions removed the
economy would flourish as never before
with controls taken off business
existing enterprises would expand and
new ones would spring into existence
satisfying more and more consumer needs
millions more people would be gainfully
employed instead of subsisting on
welfare and all kinds of research and
production released from the
stranglehold of government would
proliferate fulfilling man's needs and
desires as never before it's always been
the case whenever government permitted
people to be free traders on a free
market
history doesn't actually bear that out
of course especially recent history
where we see that but hospice is writing
in an earlier time and there are still
many people who view the solution to all
of our problems in a libertarian way
namely get the government out of it and
allow the free market to decide and this
brings us to another interesting point
that's not discussed here but is well
worth considering
is it only government that can do the
sorts of things against individuals that
libertarians have a problem with
or do businesses sometimes do those
sorts of things as well particularly the
larger they are and the more of a
stranglehold they have on certain
sectors of the economy
are all
people who engage in the workplace
merely voluntary agents not being
coerced in any way
by the
the the
corporations or companies who they're
working with or some of them
forced into things which violate their
rights from a libertarian perspective i
leave that question open for you whether
businesses could also engage in some of
the same things policies for example you
know protecting individuals against
themselves
having a drug policy at work
right if you know is telling you that
you can't use recreational drugs in your
free time
maybe that's acting like a government
from a a libertarian perspective so i
leave that for you to think about in
light of hosper's article
you